[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 24 janvier
bienvenue dans ce nouveau 7,8 journal
sur tv 78 les titres de cette édition
est la république dans les quartiers
c'est le nom de ce séminaire qui se
tenait aujourd'hui à la préfecture des
yvelines à versailles il conviait
habitants acteurs et professionnels de
terrain dans le cadre de la mobilisation
en faveur de la politique de la ville le
but notamment améliorer l'insertion par
l'éducation et l'emploi
chaque année en france entre 2 et 6
millions de personnes sont touchées par
la grippe saisonnière des gestes simples
peuvent permettre de réduire les risques
de transmission de ces virus de l'hiver
elle nous recevons koering regard
déléguée départementale adjointe de
l'agencé régionale de santé d'île de
france dans les yvelines
enfin les salles culturelles yvelinois
s'apprête à entamer leur deuxième partie
de saison
focus ce soir sur la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt du théâtre mais aussi de la
musique et de la danse
entretien à la fin de ce journal un
procès aujourd'hui à la cour d'appel de
versailles le groupe renault est
l'ancien directeur de l'usiné de flins
sur seine
elles sont poursuivies pour homicide
involontaire en 2004 un salarié de 30
ans à mouret sur le site écrasé par une
machine de plusieurs tonnes
une relaxe avait été prononcée en mars
dernier au motif qu'aucune faute
qualifiée ne concernait les accusés le
parquet avait alors fait appel à
versailles où une centaine d'acteurs des
quartiers de la politique de la ville
étaient réunis aujourd'hui la préfecture
des yvelines organisé un séminaire
thématique la république dans les
quartiers un temps de des changes pour
sur les sujets et améliorer la
compréhension des valeurs de la
république
camille lambert a suivi cette journée
être français se sentir français laïcité
citoyenneté des notions parfois
difficile à aborder pour les habitants
des quartiers en politique de la ville
représentants d'associations élus et
acteurs sociaux ont participé à ce
séminaire en préfecture des yvelines
objectif trouver des réponses concrètes
à des questions parfois abstraites
certains jeunes nous disent la
république nous a parqué dans les grands
ensembles république doit maintenant
s'adapter à nous quand on prend
l'histoire il n'y a pas de volonté
politique de parcs et des gens dans ces
quartiers au contraire on fait face à la
construction la reconstruction après
guerre on revient sur des éléments
factuels pour se réapproprier vraiment
ce qu'il en est écoutez les acteurs de
terrain au contact des habitants les
orienter mais surtout échanger sur leur
ressenti et leurs projets comme celui de
l'association mosaïque des quevilly elle
a réalisé un film avec les jeunes de son
quartier
ce projet là en fait que ce travail en
amont a récemment permis déjà de
découvrir - même possible de couvrir les
autres donc le vivre ensemble et le côté
humain qui est important surtout à
retenir
au quotidien on peut aborder de
questionnements autour de la laïcité
parce qu'on a vu que c'est d'acheter des
choses qui font débat au niveau de la
société et le ramène à leur échelle
nous notre travail c'est de permettre
voilà de leur permettre de pâte en
parler librement des changes et une
journée qui répond au plan de
mobilisation nationale du gouvernement
sur la politique de la ville lancé en
novembre
le compte rendu de ce séminaire sera
adressée à jacques mézard ministre de la
cohésion des territoires
il est le président du sénat et est
yvelinois gérard larcher a présenté
aujourd'hui ses propositions de son
institution pour la préparation de la
réforme constitutionnelle une révision
de la constitution pour mieux contrôler
à l'action gouvernementale notamment l
ancien maire de rambouillet a réaffirmé
ses réserves sur plusieurs points
avancés par le président emmanuel macron
elle les détails dorés les roses les
collectivités territoriales ne sont pas
un problème mais une chance pour la
france depuis plusieurs mois un groupe
de sénateurs planchent sur la réforme
constitutionnelle
un chantier d'envergure lancée par
emmanuel macron en juillet dernier
devant le congrès à versailles
entre le président français et le
président du sénat gérard larcher les
avis divergent sur plusieurs points
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats dans
le temps ou encore la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires
nous proposons de préserver l'ancrage
territorial des parle
en terre en prévoyant l'article 24 de la
constitution l'élection au mois d'un
député ou d'un sénateur par département
vient s'ajouter la question du cumul des
mandats dans le temps des élus locaux et
des parlementaires qui ne paraît pas
acceptable en l'état
pour une majorité du groupe du travail
pour le sénateur des yvelines et chef de
la chambre haute du parlement il faut
avant tout préserver le lien entre les
parlementaires et nos territoires
je vais prendre un exemple montigny le
bretonneux avant-hier près de 1000
personnes
comment voulez vous que l'on dise temps
si la relation entre un parlementaire
des maires et les citoyens autre projet
qui tient à coeur gérard larcher la
ligne 18 du grand paris express sont à
venir devraient être précisées dans les
prochains jours il n'y a pas de vrai
avenir solide pour le plateau de saclay
et donc aussi de versailles à
rambouillet pour toute cette partie là
si nous n'avons pas des moyens de
transport concernant le projet de loi de
révision de la constitution il devrait
être présenté fin février par le
gouvernement et sur ce sujet justement
de la ligne 18 abordé par gérard larcher
nous en reparlerons est bien sûr dans
nos prochaines éditions et dixième jour
de mobilisation pour les surveillants
pénitentiaires à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats hier les négociations avec le
ministère de la justice sont échoués à
bois d'arcy vous le voyez sur ces
simulations ces images amateurs les
gardiens ont bloqué hier dès 5 heures du
matin l accès à la maison d'arrêt
l'intervention des crs parfois à coups
de gaz lacrymogène a été nécessaire pour
disperser les manifestants ils réclament
plus de moyens humains l'amélioration de
leurs conditions de travail et des
mesures spéciales pour les détenus à
radicaliser un nouveau débrayage est
prévu pour demain à bois d'arcy toujours
l'acte 2 pour à l'école numérique
trois ans après la ville et l'éducation
nationale ont signé hier une deuxième
convention de partenariat depuis la
rentrée de septembre les classes
élémentaires dispose notamment de trois
unités mobiles de cette tablette cinq
robots ont été mises à disposition pour
s'initier à la programmation
le numérique est également expérimentée
dans les écoles maternelles propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude
nous avons effectué déjà beaucoup de
choses en trois ans tablettes numériques
dans les dents les dans les classes b
nigré au numérique interactif dans
chaque classe des grenadines le soutien
scolaire en ligne gratuite et culmine à
beaune est aujourd'hui là on va passer à
une deuxième étape importante
nous allons équiper navy
ces cols de voleurs si avec des robots
maintenant nous allons
renforcer l'offre le cas ce mobile est
également dans les classes de
la recette des équipements qui sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement adapté à un des
enjeux majeurs pour nous c'est mieux
faire apprendre les élèves dans la
diversité de leur disposition de leurs
capacités tout au long de leur parcours
scolaire
est ce qui se fait ici une fois encore
est tout à fait remarquable et
exemplaire de cette volonté commune de
mieux faire réussir l'ensemble de nos
élèves
mais chaque année en france entre 2 et 6
millions de personnes sont touchées par
la grippe 30% des enfants de moins de
deux ans sont affectés par la
bronchiolite le les virus sont légions
l'hiver il contribue largement à rendre
notre quotidien plus morose pendant
cette période pourtant quelques gestes
simples peuvent limiter considérablement
lé risque de transmission corinne de
regards bonsoir à vous êtes la déléguée
départementale adjointe des yvelines de
la rs ile-de-france les rêves celle
agences régionales de santé beaucoup de
virus l'hiver pour citer les plus
célèbres grippe rhume gastro entérite
bronchite bronchiolite beaucoup de
personnes qui sont touchées pendant
l'hiver car ces virus en fait on forte
contagion oui tout à fait on est en
pleine période d'épidémie grippale
actuellement en ile-de-france et en
france en général
l'épidémie de la grippe elle a commencé
tout début décembre
ça a été une épidémie précoce qui a
démarré vite et assez fort le pic a été
atteint en fin d'année et donc là on est
encore en période d'épidémie même si on
est en phase descendante donc la
vigilance est toujours de mise notamment
pour pour la grippe mais aussi pour la
gastro entérite qui fait son apparition
et pour laquelle on va bientôt être en
période d'épidémie également vous voulez
vivre les petits cons décembre là on est
sur une phase descendante
même si l'épidémie n'est pas terminée
alors en ces périodes les personnes
particulièrement vulnérables ce sont les
notamment les personnes âgées et les
bébés aussi oui tout à fait les
personnes les plus fragiles vis-à-vis de
ces virus sont les personnes âgées les
personnes qui présentent des pathologies
chroniques immunodéprimées et puis
concernant le virus de la grippe
la recommandation de vaccination est
également valable pour les femmes
enceintes
alors vous l'avez dit la grippe n'est
pas encore terminée l'épidémie n'est pas
encore terminée ce qu'on sait déjà
s'il a été plus forte que les années
précédentes où on est dans une moyenne
finalement pour la grippe alors c'est
encore un petit peu difficile de le dire
mais là la grippe a démarré de manière
plus précoce et très rapidement on a
atteint le pic assez rapidement la
caractéristique de l'épidémie de cette
année et qu'elle a touché des personnes
jeunes de moins de 15 ans qui était pas
le cas de l'épidémie de l'année dernière
d'accord et il ya déjà un excès de
mortalité qui a été constaté mais il est
encore trop tôt pour avoir des chiffres
consolidés sur sur les effets de la
grippe de cette saison alors pour la
grippe saisonnière justement vous en
avez dit deux mots la vaccination ça
reste le moyen le plus efficace pour
prévenir la maladie et préserver son
entourage ce n'est pas une fin pour
autant il y aussi à cette geste dit
barrière respecter pour éviter la
transmission
le premier ça paraît évident c'est se
laver les mains alors d une étude qui a
sorti en 2016 qui disait que 39% des
français seulement se déclarent se laver
les mains après à s'être mouché 25%
après avoir pris les transports en
commun on a l'impression qu'on n'a pas
les bons réflexes encore pourtant se
laver se laver les mains c'est une
première étape importante déjà alors se
laver les mains en période d'hiver c'est
vraiment indispensable c'est le geste
essentiel pour limiter la contagion et
la transmission des virus de l'hiver
mais pour pour le virus de la grippe le
premier jet c'est le meilleur moyen de
se protéger ça reste la vaccination
d'accord la vaccination des personnes
les plus fragiles mais la vaccination
elle aussi va possible à tous les âges
et quand on se vaccine soit on se
protège pour ne pas être malade mais on
protège aussi son entourage pour lui
faire courir moins de risques de fait
d'être malade et pour renforcer l'effet
de la vaccination effectivement il ya
les gestes barrières et les gestes qui
vont limiter en fait les risques de
transmission et le lavage des mains
c'est le premier de ces gestes que l'on
doit répéter très fréquemment dans la
journée et à des moments essentiels
comme quand on rentre chez soi après
avoir utilisé les transports en commun
avant de prendre son repas
après être allé aux toilettes et
évidemment
avant de donner à manger à ses enfants
ou s'occuper de ses enfants et qu'est ce
que ça fait concrètement se laver les
mains ça va les mener les quelques
germes pour les premiers germes
on va dire qu'ils peuvent être
responsables de transmission après alors
se laver les mains effectivement ça
enlève les soudures et puis ça élimine
une grande partie des bactéries et virus
que l'on que l'on véhicule sur nos mains
faut savoir que le virus de la grippe
par exemple il reste vivant sur une
surface inertes des objets pendant
jusqu'à 12 heures donc on peut rester
contaminés même après avoir avoir touché
un objet est compté que quelqu'un
d'autre se contaminent dans son
entourage via cet objet d'où l'intérêt
aussi de nettoyer désinfecter les objets
les plus courants que l'on utilise
surtout lorsque l'on est malade alors on
peut se laver les mains le tout c'est de
bien se les laver
on n'a pas de visuel là mais
concrètement les étapes à respecter pour
bien se laver les mains à quoi doit-on
être vigilant quand on quand on se lave
les mains alors on doit se laver les
mains de préférence à l'eau chaude et
puis se savonner pendant au moins 15
secondes donc faire bien mousser le
savons
ne pas oublier le dos des mains les
ongles les jointures les poignets et
puis ensuite serein c'est bien
évidemment à l'eau claire et ce et se
sécher de préférence avec un papier à
usage unique et je vois qu'une petite
question restera sur ces fameux gel
antibactérien excuses ont une réelle
utilité
ça suffit pas j'imagine ça peut être un
premier geste quand on est dehors qu'on
n'a pas la possibilité de se laver les
mains mais en rentrant chez soi il faut
quand même avoir ce geste du lavage des
mains oui les solutions hydroalcooliques
sont efficaces pour illuminer
effectivement bactéries et virus
le lavage de mains est quand même
recommandé avant d'utiliser ses
solutions hydro alcooliques qui ne vont
pas nettoyer les mains mais qui font les
désinfecter donc si les mains sont
souillés auparavant elles ne vont pas à
ne vont pas nettoyés à ne vont pas
nettoyer les mains alors le geste numéro
deux c'est de se couvrir le nez et la
bouche quand on tousse et on éternue
tout à fait maître se couvrir le nez et
la bouche avec avec la main ou tousser
dans son coude
voilà c'est vraiment des gestes que l'on
doit que l'on doit aussi apprendre à nos
enfants à des tout jeunes le geste
numéro 3 se moucher dans un mouchoir à
usage unique c'est à dire pas de
mouchoir en tissu c'est quelque chose de
produits mais disons que si on sait nous
sur un mouchoir en tissu les virus vont
y rester
donc l'idée est vraiment de une fois que
l'on se mouche de jeter son mouchoir et
se laver les mains juste après alors un
autre geste c'est d'éviter de se toucher
le visage en particulier le nez et la
bouche pourquoi ces sept à éviter est le
fait de se toucher le visage mais parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on va se
contaminer qu'on va
qu'on va être exposée finalement au
virus et que le virus va pénétrer dans
notre organisme donc éviter de se
toucher ses parties du visage est
vraiment essentiel notamment la bouche
les menus que je mange donc ça favorise
ça alors c'est quatre gestes que l'on
vient de voir ses pour se protéger
finalement quand les virus de l'hiver il
en a d'autres à respecter là quand on
est malade
le geste numéro 5 que je voulais voir
avec vous c'est forcément quand on est
malade il faut rester chez soi
évitez de les sortir entre calais
limitée et contacter un médecin si
besoin
oui donc évidemment quand on est quand
on a des symptômes grippaux
évitez éviter d'embrasser les personnes
ne pas se serrer la main éviter les
contacts pour éviter de se contaminer et
vit évidemment appelé son médecin
traitant et éviter le recours immédiat
aux urgences passer d'abord par son nom
par son médecin traitant
donc ça ces gestes 5e geste aussi si
vous l'avez évoqué donc limiter les
contacts directs et indirects d'ailleurs
aussi via les objets quand on touche
aussi des objets faut faire attention
faut faire attention parce que le virus
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
reste reste actif sur ces objets et peu
de retransmettre peut ensuite vers
d'autres personnes donc ce sont ce sont
des vecteurs qu'il faut qu'il faut
essayer de nettoyer désinfecter
régulièrement quand on est malade
un dernier geste c'est peut-être de
porter un masque notamment lorsqu'on est
en contact avec des personnes fragiles
j'ai l'impression en tout cas que c'est
un réflexe qu'on n'a pas encore
forcément adoptés en france on voit
peut-être dans d'autres pays le fait de
porter un masque en france est pas
encore un réflexe je lance est vrai que
porter un max un masque n'est pas n'est
pas vraiment encore entré dans nos
habitudes
pourtant il sait quelque chose de très
efficace évidemment pour pour limiter la
transmission et je voudrais aussi
signalé un dernier j'ai vraiment d'aérer
son logement chaque pièce de son
logement
plusieurs fois par jour pour renouveler
l'air et respirer un air a signé un
panneau d'avoir de ses actions
complémentaires sur son logement
notamment auraient renouveler l'air
c'est là la température aussi qu'on peut
maintenir dans son logement ça peut être
un humain comportements adoptés ou pas
du tout oui mais en général une
température de 19 degrés à une
température idéale pour % de gens
dernière chose peut-être a ajouté avant
de conclure cet entretien peut-être
alors on a on a rappelé beaucoup de
gestes l'essentiel à savoir pour éviter
la transmission
pour éviter la transmission est d'être
contaminés se vacciner se laver les
mains et évitez éviter les contacts
lorsque l'on est malade et je rappelle
que vous pouvez retrouver tous ces bons
gestes pour éviter la transmission des
virus sur le site de la rs ile-de-france
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
corinne brouillard d'avoir été avec nous
je me rappelle délais liés à
départementale adjointe des yvelines de
la rs ile de france je rappelle encore
une fois ce site internet pour retrouver
à tous les bons gestes à respecter
l'enseigne et s'est installé au centre
commercial sqy ouest depuis octobre le
furet du nord a ouvert un espace de 2000
m² consacrés à la littérature d'abord
mais aussi aux loisirs créatifs et à la
papeterie à trois mois après l'arrivée
du magasin et quel est le bilan
éléments de réponse avec aurélie rose on
a fait aussi une petite table avec un
coup de coeur donc toutes les meilleures
lectures de l'équipe librairie depuis
trois mois les saint quentinois peuvent
découvrir l'offre culturelle proposée
par l'enseigne furet du nord
un réseau de 17 magasins répartis dans
le nord et en ile-de-france à skywest on
peut y trouver 40 mille références de
livres et 15 mille produits loisirs
chaque jour on a de nouveaux clients
donc c'est chouette de voir que une
vraie progression tous les jours et on
est très contents de nos résultats
jusqu'à présent avec des week-ends
avec beaucoup beaucoup de familles qui
viennent des vacances scolaires qui
fonctionne super bien
en plus de la littérature l'enseigne
s'est diversifié ces dernières années
avec des produits de loisirs créatifs du
multimédia de la papeterie ou encore des
jeux pour enfants une offre qui s'étend
ici sur près de 2000 m² nous sommes
venus au cinéma et on a vu cette
enseigne nouvelle donc voilà c'est une
découverte
la première impression c'est l'espace
quand on passe devant la porte laborde
l'impression que ces petits séance de
dédicaces démonstrations de jeux
ateliers de loisirs créatifs
l'enseigne mise également sur
l'événementiel pour attirer la clientèle
qu'elles soient adultes ou plus jeunes
c'est très important pour nous de faire
vivre à nos clients différentes
expériences en magasin les gens sont
très demandeurs
et là notre prochain événement c'est la
nuit harry potter pour les 20 ans de la
sortie du livre harry potter qu'on
organise tout un tas d'animations dont
le magasin a commencé par une cérémonie
de répartition avec le choixpeau pour
savoir dans quelle maison on va être
envoyée donc il ya des êtres des
ateliers qui sont pour les plus grands
mais aussi pour les plus jeunes
son communiqué de chiffres le magasin
furet du nord à skywest confie avoir
atteint ses objectifs
après trois mois d'ouverture avant
d'enchaîner sur la suite ils viennent de
nous être communiqué les derniers
chiffres du chômage dans le département
en décembre dans la catégorie a le
département enregistre en décembre une
baisse de 0,3 pour cent du chômage en
décembre 6 168 milles un peu plus de six
cent soixante huit mille demandeurs
d'emploi étaient dans le département en
catégorie à
je précise que c'est une tendance qui
est supérieur aux chiffres nationaux où
la baisse a été enregistrée en décembre
à 0 1%
dernier chiffre à vous adonner c'est la
baisse sur trois mois dans les yvelines
qui est à 0 6%
il est en lice parmi a les plus beaux de
france le marché notre dame à versailles
a été sélectionné pour un concours
organisé par le parisien le journal le
parisien et la chaîne tf1 le lieu
accueille tout au long de l'année
touristes et habitants du quartier et
des alentours notre dame plus beaux
marchés de france les neiges
et miquel et demi d'euros sont année sur
place pose la question le marché notre
dame est un lieu incontournable pour la
vie de la ville de versailles
trois matinées par semaine le micro
village de la place du marché s'anime
fruits et légumes en tous genres fromage
viande ou encore plats préparés tout
tiller alors quand on demande aux
visiteurs ce qu'il pense du lieu est ce
que c'est le plus gros marché de france
bah oui bien sûr parce que c'est
versailles ya du choix par rapport à la
promesse je pense que ça n'a rien à
envier aux marchés traditionnels de
province les commerçants l'ambiance
les produits tout est bien il est très
charmant caractéristiques de cette place
13 convient aéré versailles notre dame
est le plus beau marché français le plus
accueillant
construit sous louis xiii le marché est
d'abord un lieu d'histoire
il s'étend dans d'anciennes halles et
sur une place un peu excentré du château
de versailles
les commerçants sont fiers de travailler
sur cet emplacement emblématique tresse
selon vous le marché oui pourquoi cette
diversité salvayre parce qu'on a à
versailles 1 c'est la ville des rois les
votes du concours pour le plus bon
marché de francs seront clôturées le 15
février prochain les 24 marchés encore
en lice auront la chance d'être mise à
l'honneur lors du journal de 13 heures
de jean pierre pernaut avant l'annoncé
officielle du vainqueur à l'aller avant
de se quitter beaucoup de théâtre mais
aussi de la musique et de la danse la
saison continue à la ferme de bel ébat
l'une des salles culturelles de
guyancourt en ce début d'année à 2018
c'est l'occasion de faire le point sur
la programmation est mélanie potier et
camille lambert ont rencontré le
directeur de la ferme de bel ébat
entretien il y aura de la vabre la
saison a repris chez vous le 13 janvier
dernier avec otouto vers autobiographie
d'un ours en peluche c'est une création
à l'image de cette deuxième partie de
saison que vous présentez 13 création
oui boucher chaque année un beau coup de
création à la ferme de bel ébat c'est un
petit peu la marque de fabrique du lieu
on essaye fkih monde de soutenir les
artistes au moment où ils en ont le plus
besoin à dire au tout début de leur
processus de création et notamment une
date de 17 mars
l'imparfait de la compagnie la jolie
pourquoi ai-je oui c'est un spectacle
qui jouera dans le cadre du festival
odyssée en yvelines festival dont
comment biennale pour le théâtre et la
jeunesse organisée par le centre
dramatique national de sartrouville et
des yvelines une très belle création
d'olivier base à l'udc qui a eu lieu
d'ailleurs au festival in d'avignon et
c'est un spectacle que nous présentons
en lien avec l'école des parents de
guyancourt un spectacle jeune public
donc à partir de 8 ans et qui met en jeu
toute les questions éducatives fait
c'est l'histoire de deux parents qui
voudraient bien avoir un enfant parfait
mais ce que l'enfant parfait existe
c'est toute la question
et voilà c'était vraiment très très joli
spectacle pour décomplexer lé
rang et les enfants sur les attentes des
uns et des autres donc les créations
chez vous c'est important aussi
oui parce que voilà cc c'est vrai que
les artistes ont besoin de théâtre qui
les accueille au moment où comprennent
la décision avant même que le spectacle
soit vu donc voilà où chaque année une
vingtaine de spectacles sont choisis
sans qu'on ait pu les voir c'est une
confiance qu'on accorde aux artistes et
c'est une confiance qu'ils honorent
souvent de très belle manière et souvent
des artistes qui reviennent que vous
avez déjà connu sur peut-être d'autres
spectacles
on essaie de faire varier les artistes
en général on refuse de programmer deux
saisons de suite les mêmes parce que le
public a droit à une grande diversité
c'est important mais en même temps comme
comme vous dites on essaye aussi d'être
fidèle aux artistes qu'on aime dont on
apprécie particulièrement le travail et
donc de saison en saison on en retrouve
quelques-uns c'est vrai que parfois on
commence par proposer un spectacle déjà
créé une compagnie et après on décide de
leur faire confiance sur un nouveau
spectacle vous le dites proposer chaque
année des choses différentes et ça se
voit vous avez de nombreuses lacunes
serait ce qu'entre janvier et mai 34
date encore à voir et tous les styles se
mêlent aussi oui ce sont des saisons
gourmandes 1 il ya vraiment beaucoup de
choses on essaye de toucher tous les
genres la danse la marionnette la
musique le théâtre contemporain les pays
déficitaires et de l'humour où il n'a
pas toujours eu la ferme de bel ébat
mais c'est vrai que ça fait pas de mal
non plus de se faire du bien et aidé
rigoler à partir du moment où ce rire et
quand même gérer assez intelligent assez
perspicace on essaye et et pour tous les
âges à partir voilà là on va avoir de la
danse à partir de 1 an
des spectacles pour adultes pour enfants
on essaie d'en offrir pour tous les
goûts tous les genres tous les âges tout
azimut
vous intégrez aussi à des festivals vous
parlez de 10 en scène tout à l'heure il
ya syndrome pu qui sera joué lors des
rencontres et ne citer que le théâtre de
saint quentin et il vient sacrée musique
ça continue parce qu'il ya deux dates à
ne pas rater alors la première l'on
surveillait ses légendes ses lèvres
légende celle est donc un récital
consacré à hildegarde de bingen donc la
première grande compositrice occidentale
du 12e siècle mais qui est également une
grande abbès visionnaire architectes
docteur en médecine
voilà on la connaît beaucoup aujourd'hui
pour ses tisanes et tout voilà tous ces
remèdes à base de plantes qui sont
encore très très couru
sacrée musique est ce que ça se joue
chez vous vous sortez alors ce sera à
l'elysée alain victoire les deux
derniers concerts de sacrés musique se
joueront à l'église saint victor de
guyancourt donc une très belle petite
église qui a été restauré il ya assez
peu de temps donc ce récital de garde
von bingen est également le concert
suivant
et justement le concert suivant c'est le
dernier c'est le 25 mars cette fois et
on parle de leçon des ténèbres les
leçons de ténèbres de françois couperin
voilà ce sera notre dernier concert par
l'ensemble les mouvements de l'âme
un très beau récital les leçons de
ténèbres de couperin donc c'est une
oeuvre écrite pour la semaine sainte
avant pâques
et ça fait partie des plus belles pages
de la musique baroque française
merci à yoann l'avam alors certaines
dates sont complètes ou quasi complète
mais n'hésitez pas à passer toujours un
coup de fil à la ferme de bel ébat et
toutes les dates et les réservations
sont à faire sur le site internet de la
ferme
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal je vous
rappelle cette information qui nous est
parvenu au cours de l'édition est le
chômage en léger recul dans les yvelines
au mois de décembre le département qui
enregistre une baisse de 0 3% sur un
mois et ce pour la avec catégorie à ce
journal les reportages vous pouvez bien
sûr les retrouver comme d'habitude sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]